new GOP will need to embrace Liberty in
both the economic and the personal
sphere hi I'm Matt wells for recent TV
we're here at the annual Conservative
Political Action Conference CPAC as it
is known see what the grassroots of the
party has to say about the future over
the divided GOP soul particularly in the
wake of last week's epic filibuster by
Rand Paul you know you're walking to
seat back and immediately hit with a
bunch of crazy stand with Rand posters
head King you're behind this did the
world change after the pilla blizzard I
think if anything it made people realize
the trend that was already occurring
that young people especially
independents and actually mainline
Republicans want a return to the
Constitution the GOP of old has grown
stale and moss-covered a Republican to
date it seems like most of the push for
Liberty is within the Republican Party
but I wouldn't consider myself a party
loyalist actually seeing all these
people walking around who would normally
you know the older crowds you wouldn't
really expect them so much to support
Ron Paul in the past unfortunately and
although he did have older supporters it
tend to be more of a young crowd well
now it seems like everybody supports
Rand Paul and I ask everyone who values
Liberty to stand with me I really loved
his filibuster but there was at one
point where he was saying something like
we're creating more terrorists through
our actions and anytime anybody starts
blaming America it gives me pause two
and a half years ago through a lot of
defense Hawks saying that Rand Paul
isn't one of us when it comes to foreign
policy what's your view on that well I
think he's trying to straddle a bit to
the extent it's a charade and conceals
what is really more or less you know
sort of an isolationist view that would
mean it isn't gonna work out I think but
I'm hopeful that he means it and that
there's an opportunity to you know work
with people like him I like Rand Paul a
lot and
it's nice to see people having a
different view on foreign policy and
within the Republican Party which has
been so neoconservative for so many
years I think that there's going to be a
change I do our conservatives reacting
differently now has there been a shift
in the way they respond to law
Enforcement Against Prohibition oh yeah
my first CPAC was seven years ago and
people did not like me at all they hated
the shirt they hated the message of less
government less government control and
then their personal lives etc they
wanted the government to come into your
house and have you enforce the rules
today it's a totally different world now
post Ron Paul where now everybody under
40 agrees with me right off the bat and
even those over 40 are mostly coming
around